meine damen und herren also mitte der
sendung der müssen wir das ganze noch
mal ein bisschen größer anschauen und
machen das ganze zusammen mit professor
schuh direktor des center for global
studies an der universität in bonn
hervor rufen nach dass sie hier waren
sind vielen dank
gucken wir mal auf das große ganze was
bedeutet dieser angriff der amerikaner
auf den iranischen general im irak in
diesem fall ja gewesen für die weitere
für sagen wir mal die weltpolitik für
die gesamte weltpolitik ist das
natürlich ein sehr schlechter empfang
für 2020 weil diese angriff wirkte an
der riesengroßes potenzial die
stabilität in der regierung noch ist
liebe insbesondere wenn er es nicht mehr
zu kontrollieren wäre die eskalation
man weiß es noch nicht welche
vergeltungsmaßnahme terrain ergreifen
wie wird das ist eine offene frage
agieren fahren muss man damit rechnen
das terrain was unternehmen würden die
frage ist in welcher form zu welchem
zeitpunkt und welches hier
und dafür müssen wir vorbereitet sein
weil iran ist offensichtlich eine
meister in asymmetrische kriegführung
das heißt in graue zone ist das land
sehr geeignete in der lage liess kriege
oder aber auch überraschen angriffe
vorzunehmen
das muss auch nicht die militärische
angriffe seien sondern andere mögliche
maßnahme die wahrscheinlich auch die
schlechter stellt amerikaner treffen
wird genau für diese angriffe war ja der
general kassim sulejmani bekannt und man
hat ihnen ja auch das mastermind genannt
hinter vieler solcher nadelstiche wenn
ich es mal etwas doch salopp sagen darf
höre ich daraus dass aus ihrer sicht
diese tötung sulaimani es
nachvollziehbar für sie ist und im
zweifel auch gerechtfertigt oder
verständlich
ich habe aus einer rede genau
analysierte man hört von ihrem aus dass
der weg von der gras sondern man wie
weit geöffnet werden auch ohne ihn das
heißt das thema offensichtlich bereit
ist auch nicht überrascht durch diese
angriffe
ich vermute mal das terrain persönlich
also als hauptstadt
als militärische machte nicht unbedingt
einen selbstmord begingen werden um
amerikanische militär stützpunkte
anzugreifen aber teheran hat tausende
von tausende penis gruppen freunde
kreise in der region zum beispiel
hesborn a da braucht man nur eine eine
kleine signale sind denn dank sind die
kräfte mobilisiert und das ist
eigentlich ein zeichen dafür das terrain
nicht am wenige winzige punkte
eine große maßnahme die auch dem gewicht
von dem getöteten general rechtfertigen
eine frage die an sie die ich heute noch
nicht gehört habe und es verwundert mich
ein wenig diese tötung des generals auf
irakischem staatsgebiet verstößt die
denn aus ihrer sicht nicht gegen das
völkerrecht
doch das ist eine sehr ambivalente es
ohne die regierung im irak in bagdad hat
heute schon protestiert er jammerte
gegenüber us armee hat die regierung
nicht wo ich hier nicht konsolidiert
nicht bestätigt aber auch nicht
informiert über angriff es ist eine
frage wie man vereinbart hatte zwischen
bagdad und washington es gibt eine
vereinbarung für die stationierung der
us soldaten aus der sicht der der
irakische regierung das ist
offensichtlich eine vorgerichtliche um
erlaubte aktion aber für die amerikaner
die argumentieren durch die präventive
präventive kriegführung das heißt um
sich zu verteidigen
er fühlt sich berechtigt diese diese tür
problem also letzte frage mit der bitte
um eine kurze antwort
also das ist ja nun keine ob das ein
bruch des völkerrechtes ist ja nun nicht
entscheidungen nur eines staates oder
des anderen was vielleicht noch ein
bisschen breiter in der region gefasst
was bedeutet denn das jetzt für die
region für israel für den erzfeind irans
da ist jetzt schon die alarmbereitschaft
ausgerufen worden
premier netanjahu ist zurückgekommen aus
so von von griechenland also was
erwarten sie in der regel ich erwarte in
der region keine sammler
unkontrollierbare ist calcium hasborner
wieder nicht so dumm sein israel
anzugreifen war ja lieber einen gerade
sich befindet sich eine sehr schwere
krise und auf saudi araber werde auch
nächste weitere rang und reale befinden
sich gerade ihr eine versöhnungsprozess
ermittelt wo der vermieter durch die
durch arabische immigranten das heißt
saudi arabien terrain wird nicht
angreifen aber auch israel werde manches
maschinen wahrscheinlich in einer region
voraus habe
nach ostern werde was passieren was auch
schlimmeres professor zu wo google
direktor des global center des center
for global studies und auch inhaber des
lehrstuhls für internationale
beziehungen an der universität bonn
vielen dank dass sie hier bei uns bei
phoenix war